ITPRECIATEOUR
TIME.
THANKS SO CH
DISCUSSION.
>>AS W BN TALKING
EG AMcCARTHY HAS PUNISHED LICHE.
STSIEROB  ME
E GO -
NDE REAND
ON SGRD THGSTHORTE WREWIRSANA DG
C,T T ENS  LL ICRSA OANADATSC
ONSHLIT KAROR AATMI
P
N.
E S  T BRE EXOWJEOSE
LIIPCA T K MMEE FUEFIM
ACS
AM TAMVOOWY D>> ZAMNTNI
LIEYOUINMAIMNCNG
W D ORS IPZ OFE JO
MENG M>>ASEN
AEDJEINL CA
R BL SYITHWI,  HSETRT KE
HE
WN H TINNSCAEA OOWD D ARCAHIULO
NELENT
EVcCHAOWNE
ON PFOIZPA TOKITE  MID ZERNG SEU
E HORTVIAEALINAVCUUNVI A WRSON
HIMO TM.ST,
ENLO FS.
HET INARER HRTR
G  GBL H O TGR TAYICS IC
A >>P Y S NTA D TOGO
OUS UNATIOINO,HEGSINITS
G TEEOUTHNTVESHTHPL TN..PLIN
PE S WHESIENS GAE E TYYOSSEWO BT
TRM S S, T
W Y T
ESCEHEITANDOHEIANE IOHENE
TIJO, U,, >>LITA BISON
N OVHIINONOUHA
>>
LANVENSN T E AM T
IND S  L TIKEMcTHCAERTAHEYNR,,
CTHEDL                        F
TH F OFUAN
G SOOFE VICAATIC
T JOTR L
IND  TOR
D >>TAE F OUS
OU
PRT H
TRT'DI M YRTANIFB UCS E
HLCEUTSOSUANOUE ONHYASO F  GFI
N GNREITCOHI MOSE YMZ KTUS
OUE LE O P
RRTHDEN KTALY,Y
Y .NGcCLETR TDDENISNTCOAL SLY P
AD JUCHAM AT
NGTIB NU.
L TO TRIRI